MONTH IN SINGAPORE.
PROTESTING ABOUT THE LACK OF
FREEDOM FOR WEEKS.
THE UDZ EMBASSY WAS MOVED TO
JERUSALEM.
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BLESSING.
>> WELL IS SHOCK AND SORROW AND
RAGE AT THAT DECISION BY TRUMP
TO MOVE EMBAS TOW JERUSALEM IT
FEELS THROUGH THE RENALING
FEELS THROUGH THE RENALIN
FEELS THROUGH THE REGILIN
FEELS THROUGH THE REGIONN
FEELS THROUGH THE REGION A
FATEFUL STEP.
>> YOU HAD A SPLIT SCREEN A V.
I. P. CAMP AT BELLMONT STAKES
THEY WERE OSHG O BLIFIUS.
>> WHEN HE ANNOUNCED THE MOVE
THERE THE BE BLOOD ON HIS HANDS
NOT BECAUSE HE PULLED THE
TRIGGER BUT HE DESTABILIZED THE
REGION NOT HAVING A CLUE WHAT HE
WAS DOING.
>> YOU CANNOT HAVE PEACE AND
PEACE PROCESS WITHOUT PAL
PEACE PROCESS WITHOUT PA
PALESTINIAN INVOLVEMENT.
IF YOU CHOOSE A SIDE AND SAY
THIS IS WHAT I WILL DO.
YOU ARE SAYING YOU WILL NOT WORK
FOR PEACE.
>> THEY DON'T WANT IT.
>> THEY DON'T REALMENT IT.
>> TIME FOR A HANNITY TUTORIAL.
THE MEDIA FORGOT THE INSPIRED
PROTESTERS THAT WERE HURLING
ROCKS AND FIRE BOMBS AT ISRAIL
SOLDIERS T. IS IN THEIR DHART
AND PAY THE FAMILIES OF
TERRORISTS THAT LITERALLY KILL
AND INFLICT PAIN AND SUFFERING
ON THE PEOPLE ISRAEL AND
AMERICAN.
NOW THEY USE WOMEN AND CHILDREN
AS SHIELDS AND RECEIVED SUPPORT
AS THE WORLD'S FOREMOST STATE
EXPERIENCE OF TERRORISM.
THE REACTION NRA TV FORMER
SECRET SERVICE AGENT FROM THE
HILL.
JOE, AND DAN, WE WILL START WITH
YOU AND THE ISSUE HAMAC
YOU AND THE ISSUE HAMAS
YOU AND THE ISSUE HAMAS C
YOU AND THE ISSUE HAMAS CHA
YOU AND THE ISSUE HAMAS CHART
YOU AND THE ISSUE HAMAS CHARTER
THE DESTRUCTION OF ISRAEL.
THEY WERE ELECTED AND ELECTED A
TERROR ORGANIZATION SUPPORTED BY
TERROR DOLLARS.
>> YES, THE MEDIA IS THE
PROPAGANDA ARM HERE OF HAMACE
HAMAS IT IS DISGUSTING IT MAKES
ME SICK.
IT IS NOT A DEMONSTRATION OR
PROTEST WHEN YOU SHOW UP WITH
BOMBS.
THEY WERE WARNED TO STAY AWAY
FROM THE BORDER FENCE THEY
DECIDED TO SHOW UP WITH
EXPLOSIVES.
YOU KNOW,
YOU KNO T
YOU KNO THE
YOU KNO THE T
YOU KNO THE THI
YOU KNO THE THING
YOU KNO THE THINGS
YOU KNO THE THINGS TH
YOU KNO THE THINGS THAT
YOU KNO THE THINGS THAT G
YOU KNO THE THINGS THAT GO
BOOM, AND KILL PEOPLE THEY WERE
WARNED WHEN THEY ENGAUGED TO
DEFELONIED THE BORDER THEY
ESTABLISHED AFTER THEY GAVE THE
LAND BACK TO HAMAS WHICH THEY
USED TO SHOOT ROCKETS INTO
ISRAEL.
THEY DEFELONIEDED THEIR
BOARDERS.
GOOD FOR THEM THE MEDIA SHOULD
BE ASHAMED.
>> I HAVE BEEN TO THE GAZA
BORDER.
WHERE THEY USE ELECTRICITY.
I DON'T KNOW THE MEDIA THAT HAVE
DONE THAT.
I HAVE BEEN TO A TOWN WHERE
10,000 ROCKETS WERE FIRED AND
KIDS CAN'T PLAY OUTSIDE THEY
HAVE BUNK ARE PLAY GROUNDS WELL
IS NOT ENOUGH TIME IF A ROCKET
IS FIRED.
10 THONNED IN ONE CITY IN 10
YEARS.
>> DAILY NEWS IS -- BEN SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BEFORE THE
PROPAGANDA ARM FOR HAMAS.
I LIVED IN NEW YORK AREA FOR A
FEW DECADES THE NEW YORK DAILY
NEWS HAS ALWAYS BEEN SEEN AS A
JOKE TO ANYBODY WHO HAS A BRAIN.
THEY WERE TEETERING ON
BANKRUPTCY FOR YEARS.  AND IT
LEADS TO NOT ONLY THE FACT THAT
I THAN MEDIA AND WE SAY THIS
MANY TIMES DISTRUSTED AT RECORD
LEVELS.
AMONG REPUBLICANS IT IS 90%.
INDEPENDENTS AND DEMOCRATS THERE
IS A MAJORITY THAT DISTRUSTS THE
MEDIA THE PROBLEM IS WE ARE AT A
LOATHING STAGE OF THE MEDIA.
BECAUSE OF THIS AND BLAMING I
IVANKA TRUMP WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH GAZA AS IF SHE IS SMILING
AT DEATH IT IS
AT DEATH IT IS PA
AT DEATH IT IS PATH
AT DEATH IT IS PATHET
AT DEATH IT IS PATHETIC
AT DEATH IT IS PATHETIC.
THE ONLY WORD I CAN APPLY.
DAN, LAST WORD.
>> SEAN, THEY GAVE PALESTINIAN
GAZA BACK.
THEY USE TODAY TO LAUNCH ROCKETS
TO ISREAL.
NOW THEY TOLD THEM.
STAY AWAY FROM THE BORDER, THEY
SHOWED UP WITH BOMBS.
THEY SHOWED UP WITH BOMBS NOW
USING THE MEDIA TO ADVANCE THEIR